hello my name is sletlana falimanova and
i am associate professor at the
department of plant pathology at the
university of florida
first of all i would like to thank the
organizers
of the lab roots microbiology virtual
week
for the invitation and for the
opportunity to present this talk at this
session
and today i would like to focus on the
role of virus host interactions
in tissue trapeze of plant viruses
to establish to establish
uh infection plant viruses need to
effectively invade
and spread within their hosts
most viruses are typically introduced
into a plant
by epidermal or mesophyll cells
in which they disassemble replicate
translate their proteins and assemble
nutrients
viruses then move cell to cell until
they reach plum
and the phloem serves as the highway
by which plant viruses spread throughout
their hosts
compared with the movement of viruses in
non-fluent tissues
virus entry long-distance translocation
and exit from the forum typically
requires additional viral factors and
complex
virus-host interactions probably because
phloem has involved additional
protection against these molecular
hitchhikers
on the other hand an increasing evidence
suggests that viruses are capable of
effectively manipulating forum for their
advantage
a recent study examined the translator
of uninfected versus tobacco mosaic
infected arabidopsis taliana and tobacco
plants
and revealed that phloem responses to
the virus infection were several fold
higher
than responses in non-fluent tissue and
most processes were altered only in the
phloem
the researchers further demonstrated
that tobacco mosaic virus
reprograms companion cell transcription
by disrupting nuclear localization of
auxin in dollar acetic acid
transcriptional regulators
via recruitment by the tobacco mosaic
virus
replicates to the cytoplasm
and these events result in the
enhancement of fluid loading
of the virus and its systemic transport
most viruses are capable of infecting
most types of cells
in a plant horse however there are
several groups of plant viruses
which tissue tropism is limited to the
phloem
these viruses are typically inserted
directly into the phloem
by vectoring fluid feeding insects
it could be hypothesized that
viruses that are confined to particular
tissue
have simplified movement systems
however the opposite is true
for instance luteoviruses that are
flowing limited viruses
have four proteins that are required for
their effective movement
within a phloem cluster viruses
have even more complex movement
machineries
cluster viruses require at least five
proteins
for their spread within their plant
hosts
and these proteins involve the major
and minor code proteins a
viral homolog of cellular heat shock
proteins in the family hsp 70
p61 a small hydrophobic protein p6
and in addition citrus crystal cluster
virus also needs two additional proteins
p33 and
the viral leader protein is l2 which
mediate virus movement
in a host dependent manner whether these
all these proteins work in concert
or mediate individual facets of
virus translocation is unknown
um plant viruses that are limited to the
form
also are capable of manipulating phloem
and one such example comes from plant
rio viruses
that induce proliferation of flow and
perennial cells
and seed elements uh which results in
formation of tumors
and these tumors create favorable
favorable environment
for virus multiplication
recently we published a review that
discusses
a current knowledge of the virus caused
interactions
and particularly focuses on the
interactions of plant viruses with the
fluorine
and this review in addition to
discussing virus
manipulation of the phloem um discusses
also
additional interesting and exciting
concepts
uh such as the possibility that viral
rna
hijack uh endogenous fluorum rna
transport system which allows viruses to
move in the form of rna
associated with plant
rna binding proteins or
a recent discovery that viruses
can move and translocate within their
hosts in the form of entire replication
complexes
today uh in my presentation i would like
to ask
address another important question and
discuss factors and processes that
mediate fluorine limitation flowing
restriction of phloem limited viruses
based on a certain observations that
have been done by different research
groups two hypotheses
explaining phloem restriction of certain
viruses
have been suggested according to the
first one fluent restriction could be
due to the lack of viral
factors facilitating infection in
non-fluent cells
for instance citrus trystanza virus was
able to
partially overcome and escape from
phloem
when its silencing suppressor was
overexpressed
and a caused rna silencing response was
downregulated
fluid restriction could also be a virus
control
function that allows the virus to
maximize
its titres at the feeding sites of
vectoring insects
such as was demonstrated in a study
with the plant palera virus
in our recent work we recently
discovered
another possible mechanism that limits
certain viruses to the phloem and this
mechanism
is regulated by the plant-host
immune system and i would like to
discuss
our work with this introductory slide
that
illustrates a multi-layered system
that plants have evolved to perceive and
defeat pathogens
the major antiviral responses
in plants include innate immune
innate immunity pathways which are
treated by the recognition of specific
viral proteins or double-stranded rna by
specialized plant receptors
and this recognition treats production
of reactive oxygen species
in induces uh fetal hormones such as
salicylic acid
signaling pathways elevates
production of defense genes and overall
transcriptional reprogramming
and in some cases also results in
programmed cell deaths
in plants however recognition of
double-stranded rna
also induces another host defense
mechanism which is rna silencing
or rna interference which is mediated by
small rnas and leads to the sequence
specific degradation
or interferes with translation of viral
rna
among other defense pathways are
transcriptional repression
and autophagy or ubiquitination mediated
the
degradation of viral proteins
we are working with citrus tristasivirus
the largest and most complex member of
the gloucester viridia family
it has long flex experience of unique
morphology so-called
rattlesnake structure built of two
capsid proteins
which cover the genomic rna which size
is approximately 20 kilobase
the natural host range of ctv is limited
to citrus in which the virus infects
fluorine associated cells
under the laboratory condition the virus
also would infect
a herbaceous nicosiano bentemiana host
the virus is transmitted by aphids and
by
infected bloodwood and in citrus
causes two major diseases quick decline
which is
deaths of citrus trees grafted onto the
sour orange rootstock
and stampeding which severely affects
sweet oranges grapefruits and lying
trees
irrespective of the root stock and
results from the abnormal vascular
development
and used by the virus the 9.3 kilobase
genome of ctv
encodes 12 open reading and contains 12
open reading frames and encodes which
include
proteins involving virus replication
movement virion assembly
three rna silence suppressors and three
proteins
p18 and p13 and p33
p18 and p13 which extend
the virus or strange however many citrus
varieties could be infected
with the virus variants in which these
three
genes were deleted and we are
particularly interested
in understanding the role of the p33
protein
in virus infection
this study began with the demonstration
that citrus tristas virus infection
triggers accumulation of reactive oxygen
species
in the citrus host as well as in a
herbaceous
horse nicotine bentemian this
was demonstrated by using staining
with the amino benzene which detects
hydrogen peroxide
production of reactive oxygen species
upon ctv infection also was accompanied
by
elevation of two hypersensitive response
marker genes and also three genes of
pathogenesis-related proteins
in order to assess which
protein of citrus prestigiovirus or
proteins
are responsible for this phenotype for
production of reactive oxygen species
we overexpressed 15 ctv proteins
and examined their ability to induce ros
and necrotic reaction in leaves of
nicotinamide
plants and as a result we found that
three proteins were responsible for this
phenotype
surprisingly and somewhat unexpectedly
uh the p33 protein was one of them
the other two proteins were p23 and
petroni
and these two proteins are suppressors
of
silencing and viral suppressors of
silencing
and proteins of this type are known to
interfere
with plant immunity and thus
uh such phenotype production of arrest
and necrotic reaction in use by these
two proteins was not so much surprising
for us
and therefore we focus our further
efforts on understanding the role of the
p33 protein in this
process to um
assess the role of the p33 protein in
inducing the hosting wheel response
we compared the impact of
the wild-type virus inoculation
with that of a virus variant
in which the gene was deleted
and please note that both virus variants
were tagged uh with the green
fluorescent protein
by insertion of the green fluorescent
protein gene
in the viral genomes when these viruses
infect plants they produce their own
proteins
along with production of gdp and
therefore gp fluorescence can be
can be can serve as a marker of virus
accumulation
along with some other methods and this
was used
as one of the methods to compare titers
or levels of accumulation of these
viruses along
with some other methods based on serol
serological or reverse transcription pcr
detection and assessment of viral titers
and the first observation that we made
that accumulation of the mutant deletion
uh um virus variant
which contained a deletion of the p33
gene
so accumulation of this mutant virus was
significantly higher than that of the
wild-type virus
on the other hand this deletion mutant
did not induce high levels of ros
and also did not cause strong plant cell
deaths as you can see in
those images
to compare and to assess
whether the plant immune response in
citrus
parallels that in nicasiana bintamiana
we inoculated citrus plants young
citrus seedlings of citrus macrophylla
with these two virus variants and
examined their distribution
in situ in those plants examination of g
florescence revealed
that while the full blanks wild-type
virus
was confined to a narrow circle
of phloem associated cells
on the cross-sections through made
through the young stems of disinfected
plants
the mutant virus in which the p33 gene
was deleted
was shown in forming groups larger
groups of cells
which express gfp and apparently those
cells were infected by this deletion
mutant
and what was interesting that these
groups of cells
were not located in this narrow circle
of the phloem
but were expanding beyond the phloem
towards the xylem area to understand
uh the which
processes were responsible for such
differential tissue distribution
well we subjected these pieces
of tissue pieces of from these infected
plants
to staining with the amino benzene and
revealed
that in those tissue samples that were
collected from plants that were infected
with the full-length wild type virus
we saw the formation of dark
brown ring at the inner surface of the
fluorine
illustrating high accumulation of
reactive oxygen species
on the other hand no such formation of
ros
were noted in healthy uninfected samples
or also in samples uh collected from
plants that were infected with the
deletion
mutant virus high level of production
of ros in plants infected with the wild
type virus
also were accompanied by elevation
of the superoxide disputation gene which
is a marker gene for ros
production so this highlighted
the importance of ros production
as a part of the host immunity response
and uh suggested that p33 protein
is one of the viral factors responsible
to trigger this reaction
examination of tissue
sections using confocal microscope also
revealed that while the wild-type virus
was able to in fact own the phlegm
associated cells
the p33 deletion mutant was found
infecting immature xylem turkey cells
which indicated that the tissue trapeze
of this p33 deletion mutant was now
altered and in addition to infecting
phlegm cells
this virus was able to invade xylem
so our next question was um
how the ability of this delicious mutant
to
invade xylem cells immature xylem cells
now affects the overall differentiation
and development of vascular tissue in
citrus plants
and we assessed uh this question by
examining all the stems from trees that
were infected with the wild-type
ctv virus or stems that were infected
with the delicious mutant using
fluoroglucinol
which stains lignin in material xylem
cells
and this staining revealed that the
xylem
area in the stems collected from
uh plants that were infected with the
p33 deletion mutant
uh length magnification and had
a jagged edge appearance on the
other hand uh stems
collected from plants that were infected
with the wild-type virus
were highly lignified and the xylem area
had a typical thick
ring appearance so
these observations suggested that the
ability of the p33 deletion mutant
to invade xylem cells also
was accompanied by the perturbed
differentiation of the vascular tissue
a few years ago there was a study
that reported that deletion of the p33
gene
from the ctv virus results in the
enhancement
of stampeding one of the major disease
syndrome in use by cte
yet the question how deletion of this
gene
induces strong stampeding remained
unanswered
our work now brings an explanation for
this interesting phenomenon
and suggests that the horse
recognizes the p33 protein
which is now we can call as viral
effector
and by recognition of this viral
effector
is at the next step a host mounts a
strong and fast
cost response that uh is mediated
uh by production of reactive oxygen
species
and this host response is mounted in
the virus-infected cells and also in the
adjacent cells
and as a result virus is limited
uh within phloem and is unable to move
beyond the fluid cells
[Music]
by mounting this strong
and effective host response
host limits production of the disease
and essentially minimizes its own
damage on another hand
when we have virus in which this
effector
p33 protein is not produced
host is unable to mount effective host
response
and this way virus is able to move
further beyond phloem invade xylem cells
and continuously
perturb the differentiation of the
vascular tissue
um it's um interesting
in respect to the role of the p33
protein
uh to uh
in virus infection it's interesting to
note that although
p33 protein is not conserved among
cluster viruses few members of
the genus cluster virus encode
proteins which are about 30 kilo adult
size and their genes are situated at the
same
genomic position as that of the citrus
crystal virus
p33 gene although um
primary amino acid sequences of those
proteins are not conserved and do not
share homology all these proteins
possess a c-terminal transmembrane
domain
and n-terminal helices so we can
hypothesize that structural similarities
between these proteins could account for
similarity in functions of these
proteins
found in different cluster viruses
and at the end i would like to
uh thank a person who done most of this
study
that i was presenting today and this is
yondu sun former phd student
in our lab and now he continues to use
his relational lab
as a postdoctoral researcher and i also
would like to
thank national science foundation for
providing
for providing finding support for this
and some other studies in our lab
and i also would like to thank all of
you
for your attention thank you